trivial things weren't going to pull my  attention  it had to be things weren't going to put  my attention it had to be things that  were  i had a purpose i wanted to be one of  the best basketball players to ever play  and anything else that was outside of  that lane  i didn't have time for it at what age  did that goal become crystal clear  i made that deal with myself at 13 years  old at 13 years 13 years old  clear about it crystal clear and where  did inspiration come from  um the love of the game the love of the  game the challenge like i would watch  magic play i'd watch michael play and i  would see them do these unbelievable  things and i said you know  can i get to that level i don't know but  let's find out